[Music]
you've been on you've appeared on this
show Garfunkel and Oates yes and very
very funny act and what strikes me
though is that you come across as very
sweet and very innocent Garfunkel I know
it seems like a much edgier act then
maybe you naturally would be is that
right for sure I was singing my own
songs before so Riki Lindhome is my
singing partner together we're Garfunkel
and Oates and I moats and she's
Garfunkel we just made that up
but um but then before Ricki I was
singing songs I'd like three songs about
my dog I had two songs called the happy
song happy song number one and happy
song number two and creative yeah and
and then I met Ricky and our first song
was I probably shouldn't say what it was
cause actually you what yeah you can say
it it's alright you were nude on the
roof I don't worry about me to say it
you'll believe it later yeah sure so our
first song was called
[Applause]
oh honey you could always change it to
drum so yeah yeah we're not gonna beat
that we can't afford that
okay so so then you're saying that she
influenced you and it got but I got edgy
or edgy but people really started to pay
attention and it was very exciting and
you know we have a song about hand jobs
called [ __ ] lands rub I don't
understand job special so our specials
on Thursday so you can see that one or
another classic gods loophole what's
God's loophole well it's about they know
well I don't know what I want to know
well I care about so let me have it
that one's about girls who save their
virginity by having anal sex
[Applause]
so what else you up to these yeah well
yeah learning a lot
I knew know that there's that thing he's
told us and then the old lemon trick
you